oh there is damn it you are the person I
changed myself I didn't even get to
shoot a shot dad I miss it
and miss your failure I was like I hear
foot I was like I heard footsteps and
then I think where the hell is
everything oh there is she smelt it me
maybe we get the shot
don't tell my destiny you don't talk
about black ops for blackout blackout
for
[Music]
Eric Aaron call Judy black out the
answer to pub Jean for tonight we've
been playing it for what three days now
lightly gonna give or take what do you
guys think so far it's looking pretty
solid it's definitely gonna fill that
pub Gyan console niche like I've been a
bit janky on console and it gets the
military shooter down like great I
called you the shooting really well all
the mechanics more or less seemed to
really work and they're adding things
that Call of Duty's never had before
like I could be a chopper pilot now
which I haven't been in a long time and
with the other offerings this year in
world war ii i it's the only game right
now where i can be a chopper pilot which
is super weird but I like that a lot do
you guys like the chopper though I know
some of the things in this beta so far I
feel like they could they could crank up
a little bit like zombies even like the
chopper like the chopper in general I
feel like it's just like it seems like
not resourceful in the sense that you're
just like a sore thumb flying around
yeah but I mean like I think it's as it
serves the the means of another vehicle
but at least you're in the air right
it's I don't know I feel like it can get
you to places or get you on the
outskirts and then you can potentially
like drop in or something like that I
think it's just maybe not fully explored
yet but I can kind of see why maybe like
at first glance if you're like someone's
sitting there it's not as cool but it
sure is satisfying if you like rockets
on one day and right like you're just
trying to hunt them down and like get
them to get out of there helicopter
[Music]
one thing the game's doing really well
is the map itself so Call of Duty's
never done a map this big yeah but this
map isn't just a regurgitation of Call
of Duty it's got a ton of vertical space
it's got secret underground bunkers and
like giant skyscrapers and it's got the
asylum with with zombies and it has you
know random crates to drive around the
map I was even swimming underwater and
finding loot oh really
finding crates underwater so the the use
of this map is really good and the use
of the vertical space in this map is
also really good
and it like we keep finding things just
randomly poking around which is what
makes it so interesting yeah all in all
it's scratching an itch for me as far as
like even you know the initial drops
like I had just a pretty funny moment
you for like just landing in the
construction site picking up a shotgun
four rounds shooting a guy midair he
falls his buddy comes out to get him use
all my shotgun ammo one guy and then I
turn around under something with your
fists and it's just me my shotgun
whining just letting them back and forth
[Music]
it's got those those battery album and
so just like frantic like chaotic duels
you know like squaring off of someone so
yeah I'm enjoying it I think it's it's
like if this culmination of like all
this multiplayer that's now kind of
evolved into a battle royale like I
think it's fun because I really like the
Call of Duty shooting mechanics
personally I don't want to deal with
some of the bullet drop and things like
that so to have like a different
multiplayer mode essentially right is
I'm cool I'm happy and because I already
kind of like Battle Royale to some
degree I like for tonight
I've never been great at building so
this kind of like fills this like weird
in-between of like having a four night
or Katy type shooter and then like pub G
you know like picking up stuff right in
the middle and until we see battlefield
I think this is gonna fit in like pretty
nicely with the other two that are out
there right now especially on the on the
console front yeah sure that's a really
good way of putting it it's like right
in the middle of fortnight and pub G
like for me I never gonna have a PC at
home but I was never like all in on pub
G like some people in the office and now
that this is on ps4 it's like it's kind
of checking the boxes as far as someone
who might want to give the Battle Royale
another shot cuz for tonight yeah you
mentioned like the building and that big
fan of and in general like you know it
is kind of like a cartoonish looking
game but here it's like okay it's call
duty it's familiar it's one piece for my
friends play it seems like it's gonna
have like a lot of legs for a lot of
people I guess it's being a fortnight so
battle royale is a lot of hiking and
some people like that and for some
people it's a bit dull just a couple gun
flies in between fortnight has been so
good
at making so many other things to do
around the Battle Royale there's
constant challenges there's constant
things you're trying to earn their
stories being told in that game and it's
weird to play Call of Duty game that
doesn't reward you for everything that
you do because Call of Duty pioneered
that they pioneered the world war
players for doing everything and to have
a beta that doesn't tie into their
normal reward system feels a little bit
weird so what I'd like to see them try
next and I think you're talking about
this is they got to get those motes
rotating they got to get more zombies in
maybe like big team battles snipers only
like I know we're just starting off in
the data but these are the guys who
invented rewarding players and it's
absent right now and and I think that's
gonna hurt their longevity if they can't
get it back in but they're the best in
the business event so I'm excited to see
how they how they filter all their crazy
ideas back in yeah I definitely think
that I would hope that that's a part of
what they're going for because you know
cosmetically there's a lot of ways you
can you know as for night and and other
games are shown really succeed they're
right for the battle royale mode and you
know on top of that as you mentioned
just now today having fast collapse
having the circle coming closer
or sooner sorry I'm sure they're gonna
have a bevy of other modes that they
could run if they want to like for
example I just thought about today as I
was talking about it like for Knight has
the like all legendary guns mode right
like they have legendary guns in Cod
battle route you could easily do that
same mode and be like every gun is a
legendary I have fun whatever right so
it'll be interesting to see once we get
out of beta
like what happens in like how many modes
they have you know how how frequent
order the change in the modes or the
weekly things that you know gets people
to come back cod is a huge player base
and I am interested to see how many
people stick to the battle royale coming
from like you know having a strong
multiplayer obviously this one's only
multiplayer there's no campaign
[Music]
indicated safe zone is advised the
things that upset me or maybe like that
I'm not so fond of right now in the beta
of a blackout though is like I'm not
super huge on like some of the UI and
like especially like the looting like
it's really awkward to you know kill
someone and yeah I want to make sure
there's no one else around but like you
also want to quickly lose something
right it's like okay I have to open a
bag and then I feel like d-pad over
while like kind of wiggling my right
thumb hoping right thumbstick so that
like I hope no one cheats me and I'm
just like trying to get through all this
stuff and also just because I don't know
all of the perks yet right so I'm
picking up all these perks and I'm like
what does that one do or what does that
one do I'm just like I'm gonna spam them
all I guess ya know similar to for me is
like just like removing attachments to
weapons like I can never get like a nice
rhythm where it's like I'll accidentally
put a scope on and I find it like
downright impossible to like take it off
put on another gun
all that UI stuff for sure is like it's
tough right like you know match
something a pub G on PC or like easy
click with like a mouse but yeah I'm
interested to see what pull through
there but you know it's an it's cool to
see like their patch notes so far like
they've been pretty persistent like
every day right adding like like duos
and then they also I think they went
from there like 80 max cap to like 88 oh
right so they're kind of starting to
push a little bit more and more I placed
88 yesterday
hopefully someday we'll get a battle
royale game that cycles people and
matches a little bit faster being dead
isn't that fun and so I wonder if these
guys don't have a good enough engine
it's hard to be with this many players
but I'd love it if you'd I just hit a
button and almost be jumping out of
another airplane again because the
amount of downtime in Battle Royale
it's there to make you care if you live
or die but it's also can get dull after
a while going back to a loading screen
particularly if you are the first guy to
die that's right well you know Aaron
sometimes you gotta take a break that's
why even like even in like Call of Duty
Black Ops more like multiplayer beta
like they were messing around with just
a load times in between matches like one
time is like 60 seconds and we finally
got used to that rhythm and I think like
went to 90 and then like me we're like
well I guess we should go and like get a
water and like come back you know grab
some snacks cuz that's how long it's
gonna take until this next match starts
so I'm sure they'll figure out a rhythm
it would be nice that you know obviously
try to get maximized as many games as
you can you can get but I definitely had
a lot of fun you know we do a stream and
we want to match you know like we played
together as a squad of four and old Nick
margarita you know in there too is like
a fun time right and I think like I said
Call of Duty there's a lot of players
I'm just curious how many people are
gonna gravitate towards better well I
had like one friend who plays a lot of
Call of Duty and he jumped in as I know
this isn't for me I just want to play a
traditional con so that that'll be the
big interesting thing for me to see but
yeah I'm having fun it's uh you know at
least for now
we'll have to wait to see
[Music]
exactly how we drilled it Hotel Sierra
you